Craig Smith in there bundles it low
Robertson spot it out in front and
then stick underneath the end line loosen
the trapezoid B for bounces in they score
they tied it Craig Smith the former PR
with 13 seconds left Dallas has come
back everyone's still standing but they're
stunned here at Bridgestone they Dodge an
Ender essentially with forsberg in behind Yanni
hawp gets it to the forehand had Wedgewood beat
I mean that Clank off per iron and the FRS had
multiple chances to get the puck down deep and
were just a mess in and around their own net
Mist actually shot it on his own goalie before
Smith tucked one home and we're headed to
overtime it appears steel cuts it off in
the slot knocked down here's a chance score
GIS 2 seconds left can you believe it it's
a pre Christmas miracle the stars have turned
it around and they're going to win this game 3
to2 yny hawen paa with a weapons grade slapper
nothing they can do on the Predator bench but
stare in disbelief at the replay on the floor
again they had multiple times where they could
change it up and get it out and haw andpa is
able to just step to it a skinny block attempt
by McCarron rip past him through Soros and stars
have extinguished a two nothing deficit and it
looks as though they're going to win it 3 to2
in Nashville Freds are so stunned they don't even
bother pulling Soros the final seconds tick off
the stars were 13 seconds away from a regulation
loss they double down with a onew hay maker and
we'll head into the holiday break with their
20th win of the season and what a way to do it